Did you come to save me?
Start
[music] Are
n't they going to eat the whole forest
Sleeping pills?
I don't know anything I'm iron-hardened and I
'm supposed to never get out Because
everyone who was here is dead Why am I staying
?
It's to let the people know that there is, I'm sure that's why I'm caught I don't punish sinners, but to make them admit their guilt.
If
so, I
'll continue to hunt heresy until
I'm satisfied My family, my servants, the
sea lions and my guardians,
those who love you
Only I have
to go through the right order, the trial
So will
Bonn be saved
One pardon?  If you can forgive me, I'll
recognize you as the devil's messenger
[music] What
they can't forgive is the devil It's not a being,
it's a being who will
be worshiped as a new god
I'm
sorry, I'm sorry,
I'm always
in favor of living
.
No, it's
okay with this